So, we have 10 more classes left in the
lecture series. Um, and in these 10
classes, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to show you how the American
Empire will fall. And I will show you
that what will replace the American
Empire is Israel, uh, what we call Pax
Judeica. Um, so for these next 10
classes, I will we will do an overview
of history and show you why history will
lead ultimately to the uh Pax Judeica.
Okay. All right. So, let's do some
questions from YouTube that my wife has
picked out. Um, she reads all the
comments. She loves reading the comments
and she sends comments to me to reply
to. Okay. So the first comment is um how
do we restore our right hemisphere or
how do we become more creative and the
answer is that you have to reject
materialism that that's the only way
okay you have to reject money you have
to reject power you have to reject
materialism in order to embrace your
creativity and your right hemisphere um
as a society what will have to happen is
a major crisis that threatens our very
existence for us to come together and
for us to be uh more altruistic and more
creative. Um a possibility is that if
you really want to activate your right
atmosphere, then you fall in love and
you have children or you could also
choose to volunteer, help other people,
uh be kind and generous to other people.
Okay, so that's how you activate your
right hemisphere. The second question is
um do you only give lessons to one
class? How's your journey to find some
LSD? Okay. So, um I have I'm only
teaching one lecture series but three
different sections. Okay. Um LSD
psychedelics, you know, I'm very
interested in psychedelics. I myself do
not want to partake in psychedelics
because I don't really understand why I
need to. I read a lot of books. Um, I I
practice a very altruistic lifestyle and
therefore I don't feel as though I need
psychedelics to break out of this
materialistic world. Okay, I'm already
connected to the divine. So, um, yeah.
Okay, let's move on.
All right, some more questions.
Um, could you make a video on how to
understand history without bias? And a
response is, first of all, it's
impossible to be unbiased. Okay. And
that's and that is correct. We're all
subjective.
Um
so
um he suggests that you have to look at
documents and try to be really critical
when you analyze documents and that's
correct as well. Okay. Uh the problem is
that often we don't have documentation
or we have documentation from only one
source. So it's very hard to do. So what
I'm trying to do um with this class is
try to propose a new theory of how to
understand history and if you adopt this
model I guarantee you that your
understanding of history will improve
and also your understanding of how the
world works will improve as well. So
there are three components to this new
history model which I call predictive
history. Okay. The first is to
understand historical patterns. And so
when you try to look at history and the
event there, you ask yourself, does this
fit into a larger pattern or model of
history? If it does, it's probably
correct. If it doesn't, then there's
something wrong here. Okay. Second uh
tool is idea of game theory. And the
idea of game theory is to understand
that all historical actors are motivated
by their interests or worldview. And so
are you looking at all different
historics and are you trying to figure
out what their best strategy is? Okay.
And the third uh facet is the idea of
religious esquetological. What this
means is that all cultures, all
individuals
have a certain religious outlook, a
religious worldview. You can often find
this worldview within their sacred text.
For example, the Bible or um the Quran.
Okay? And these texts will give you
insight as to how they perceive history
but also how they want history to
eventually develop. So you you can
understand the strategies moving
forward. Okay. All right. Um and we will
look at these three strategies
and we will adop we will adapt them for
um our historical understanding. Okay.
All right. Uh another question is
um this is really interesting. What the
question is most of the greats across
history were not Jewish. The domination
by Jews of various industries is a
relatively new phenomenon. Is it
possible that their creativity and power
is a result of political shifts in
education in the Bible? Okay, this is a
really good criticism of my previous
lecture. Um, and yeah, I mean the idea
is that maybe there's certain aspects of
the Jewish culture that makes them
dominant in an industrial capitalistic
globalized world. Um, and there is some
truth to that, but I often think about
um, Chinese people uh, because Chinese
people are extremely materialistic. Like
ch Chinese love money um, but we're not
as creative as Jewish people. So I think
that being materialistic, being
capitalistic, it's not enough. You also
need to have an element of creativity
within your culture. And that's why I
think that um the Bible helps us better
understand the success of Jews better.
Okay. So so this is a really good point
and and also what's really important to
understand is that this is a class on
intellectual speculation. Okay. We're
trying to figure out theories. We're
trying to play with ideas. There's no
truth there. Okay? So um take take
everything I say with a grain of salt.
Doubt whatever I say. Um this class is
really meant to be a platform or jumping
board for you to undertake your own
intellectual journey. Okay? All right.
So please keep that in mind. But um
we're going to look more closely at this
question today. Okay. Why is it that
Jews are so dominant? Um,
so we will look at the beginning of the
Jewish people and I'm going to the
argument to you that Israel and the
Jewish identity are constructs of the
imperial imagination.
Okay. Um, and this is hard to
understand. So I'm going to explain it
to you slowly, but the idea is that
because of its ge geographic location,
Israel has always been historically
imported. And as a result, different
empires have tried to manipulate the
identity of Israel to best um uh promote
their own agenda or policies. Okay. So,
um I know this is a hard concept to
understand, but but we'll we'll go for
it slowly. And again, we're spending
like the rest of semester on this major
thesis of ours. [snorts] Okay. So, let's
talk about history. Okay. So what we did
last week um is look at the cultures
that have emerged out of the project
collapse and which are now going to
dominate history. Okay. They are the
Greeks, the Persians and the Israelites.
Okay. Now we're going to look at how
these ideas um play out in history. But
for us to do that, we first need to
understand how history works. Now I've
identified three different patterns of
geopolitics. Okay? And I want you guys
to remember these patterns. The first
pattern is this. This is really
important. I didn't understand.
Competition within nation states are
what matter. Okay? Competition between
nation stones don't really matter or
they're not as significant as
competition within nation states. And
the idea we have here is elite of
production. So what drives a lot of
conflict is the fact that domestically
you have these different competing
factions and they're all competing for
uh power. Okay? So you have too many
elites, too few status uh positions and
so they're competing against each other
and this drives a lot of conflict. Okay,
so that's the first idea. Second idea is
that the elite have shifting loyalties.
Okay, think of Game of Thrones. I'm not
sure if you guys have seen the TV series
or read the books Game of Thrones, but
everyone wants to be king, right? And
they're going to kill their brother.
They're going to kill their father.
They're they're going to kill their
mother to be king. Okay? And so the
elite don't really have loyalties except
to themselves.
The world is just a game of thrones.
Okay. The third thing is that war can be
a mechanism to protect the status quo.
All right. The idea of equilibrium in
that sometimes the conflict is really
bad. So what you do? You start a war so
you can turn off people to get killed.
Okay? And that way you can maintain
equilibrium within your system. We'll
see this we'll see this pattern
throughout human history. Okay? So these
are the three ideas I want you guys to
remember as we move on and discuss world
history.
All right. So I want to give us an
example for us to understand. Okay.
Think of the war in states period of
China before the emergence of the first
empire, theQing empire. Okay. And as you
can see from this map, uh China is
divided into different waring states
that are all powerful. And at this time
in history, um theQing Empire, sorry,
theQing state is the poorest. is most
isolated and it is the least advanced.
Okay, you can see that Chu Xiao they are
more powerful and you can argue that
eventually one one of them would emerge
to unite all of China but they did not.
It was theqing the isolated marginalized
backward state that came to conquer. And
so the question is why this happened.
And so if we use our three principles
right we can understand why these three
states these different states are not
competing against each other. It's the
elites within these states are competing
against each other. Okay el lead over
production. So the way they manage this
is for them to use warfare in order to
maintain a status quo to create
equilibrium. Okay. And how we know is
from this time emerges the idea of
Chinese chess. Right? What is Chinese
chess? Chinese chess is the idea of
warfare that is regulated that is
ritualized.
[cough] Okay? So when we go to war, when
we battle each other, we have to respect
each other's um uh the rules of the
warfare. That's stupid. War should be
about killing the other guy. It
shouldn't be about following the rules.
Okay. Also another piece of evidence is
at this time in history
wrote the book The Art of War. This is
one of the stupidest books ever written.
Okay, I guarantee you if you follow this
book, you're going to lose the war badly
because this is this is really about how
to cheat in a heavily regulated game.
Okay, so uh things like using spies, oh
uh uh maintain a high guard. Okay, you
have they have all these rules. And
guess what? In actual war, none of these
things actually work. Okay? So, if you
look at history, I'm going to tell you
exactly how to win a war.
[cough and clears throat]
Okay? And the way you win a war is first
of all, you have to be completely
committed to winning this war. Okay?
Total warfare. Second is that if you
want to win this war, you have to make
sure that talent arises. So, you have to
be open and meritocratic. Okay? If a if
a officer of a general is winning this
war, you promote him. That sounds easy,
right? But not if your status quo power
because what's important to you is to
maintain that your family is always on
top. So if a general arises who is very
uh innovative, who's really talented,
you kill him because he's a threat to
you. Okay. So the third principle is
make sure your soldiers are happy. I
know it sounds really simple, but again,
if you're at school power, you don't
really care. Okay. Um, destroy enemy
civil centers, siege warfare. Okay. Go
and destroy the city because that's how
they produce their uh uh war capacity,
right? The food, the um soldiers, right?
Kill civilians.
The supply lines, overstretch your
enemy, divide and conquer, strike fear
in your enemy, kill their gods. Okay? If
you really want a war, if you really
want to win a war, this is what you have
to do. And we know because this is what
the Romans did. This is what the
Persians did. This is what um the Aztecs
did. This is what conquests did. Okay?
This is what the Mongols did. Every
single power that has conquered everyone
else has done all these things. Okay?
So, when they don't do these things,
it's because these different waring
states aren't actually at war with each
other. They're actually friends. Okay?
They're all intermarried with each
other. They're all trying to maintain a
status quo. They use war as a game in
order to maintain the status quo to
create equilibrium. Okay.
So this is true for Mesopotamia. Okay.
Mesopotamia is important because
remember this is the cradle of
civilization. This is where the first
empires will emerge. This is where most
technological innovation happens. This
was for the longest time the wealthiest
part of the world. Okay. So remember the
idea of Mesopotamia is that the first
citystate is Uric and then they will
develop colonies throughout the Tigers
and Euphrates and then these colonies
will come into war with each other and
they're all friends of each other.
They're all intermarried and the elite
create these highly ritualized um
warfare. Okay. And one really important
rule is that you don't kill each other's
god. Okay? Because in their religion,
the god lives in their temple. So you
don't attack their temple. But guess
what? All their money, all their gold is
in a temple. Okay? So you're not allowed
to steal each other's gold. That's
stupid. Okay? Because now um you don't
really accomplish that much with
warfare. So for the longest time, this
was the status quo. Then what happened
is a
u man named Luga Luga Zagazi. Okay.
And you can think of him as lower
nobility. So what we'll see in history
is that within a city state there's
always be a conflict between the upper
nobility and the lower low nobility.
Okay, the upper nobility is in charge.
They want to maintain the status quo.
The lower nobility want to steal that
power. Okay, this will happen in Rome
where Julius Caesar is of the lower
nobility and he will steal the power
from the upper nobility. Okay, the
people call the ultimates.
And so Lucas like Leazi is from Uma and
he's like, you know what, screw this.
These rules are stupid. I want to
conquer everyone. I want to be the top
dog. Okay. So what he's doing that's
very different from previous times is
he's now going and ransacking each of
each each city's temple. So now he has
the capacity to be able to build an
empire. Okay. But by doing that, what
happens is that the other city states
recognize him as a threat. And so they
invite mercenaries from place called
Akad to come and help them. Okay. And
this leads us to the first
world empire called the Aadian Empire um
named by Sargon of Akid. Now his name is
interesting. His name means legitimate
ruler which probably tells us he's not a
legitimate ruler. He's probably a
mercenary like David who stole the
throne. Okay? He saw an opportunity and
he stole the throne. But this is a
pattern in history where if there's if
there's competition among different city
states, the competition is not resolved
amongst themselves because they have an
equilibrium. So what happens is that an
outsider, a mercenary usually comes in
who doesn't respect the rules and he's
able to unite everyone. Okay, through
innovations. So this this is why theQing
dynasty and not the Jao or the Chu or
the Wei were able to unite all of China
because theQ dynasty was committed to
total warfare. They didn't care about
your rules. They wanted to win. Okay.
All right. So, as you can see, the
Canadian Empire stretches throughout the
fertile crescent. Okay. Um, conquers
Mesopotamia, modern Iraq, extends over
to Anatolia and captures a lot of the
Leavant. Okay. But this area, the
Leavant is historically the most
strategic location in the world. Why?
because it gives you access to Egypt,
Mesopotamia and Anatolia. Historically
the three wealthiest parts of the world.
So whoever controls the Levant is able
to always threaten Egypt. Okay? And for
most of history this part the Levant was
a Egyptian colony. But remember that
after the Bronze Age collapsed Egypt was
not was able to project power in the
Levant. And so uh the different empires
fought for the Levant in order to
threaten Egypt. Okay. So, Jerusalem is
literally the center of the world and we
will see that throughout history people
have considered Jerusalem the center of
the world both for religious reasons but
also mainly for geopolitical and trade
uh reasons. Okay.
Uh now the other thing to remember about
this area is that it's highly
competitive because it's hard to protect
Mesopotamia. Okay. is very very wealthy
but as you can see um there are these
mountain tribes over here that can
always threaten
Mesopotamia. Okay. So this is a pattern
in history where
whoever established an empire in
Mesopenia is always being threatened by
the mountains the regions sorry the the
borderlands okay this is a this is a
pattern throughout um
uh meian history and that's why these
empires change all the time. Okay. So
this is the Babylonian Empire. Uh this
this gives us uh hemorrhabi.
Okay. Then you have the uh Assyrian
Empire. The Assyrian Empire is famous
for their brutality. They'll come if you
rebel against them, they will kill
everyone. Okay? They're they're
notorious for their brutality. Now
remember at this time in history, an
empire is not the empire of today where
you can exert authority everywhere.
empire at this time is you're mainly
controlling certain choke points of
trade and everyone else just sort of
like goes along because it benefits
them. Okay, so an empire is more more
like a loose confederation as opposed to
um a nation state. Okay, so this is the
Assyrian Empire.
Um and this is the uh Neoablonian
Empire. Okay, so you have these empires
that constantly change over time.
History changes when a man emerges
called Cyrus the great. Okay. Um
[clears throat]
Cyrus the great is the founder of
something called the Persian Academic
Empire. So last class we discussed
Zoroastronism and Zoroastronism is
really the first great world religion
uh because it provides a simple but
powerful model of how the world works
and um rationalism is powerful because
it encourages everyone to be their best
right to seek Asha. Now, for most
people, what Asha means is don't ever
lie. Okay? And it is actually um a
really useful thing if you're trying to
run an empire because when you run an
empire, you need soldiers, you need
generals, you need administrators,
right? And if people don't lie, if
people are honest and moral, well, you
can expand really quickly, right? And so
that's what Cyrus the Great did. S the
great is also known for his mercy and
his generosity. So when he conquers a
place what he will do he will identify
the best people maybe the king himself
and make them advisers to his regime.
Okay he's known for his tolerance he's
own he's he's known for his um openness
and so what happens is that the
Babylonian Empire basically surrender to
him without a fight. Why? because of
elite overproduction, right? You have
this war going on between the upper
nobility and the lower nobility and
they're like, you know what? Let's just
invite Syus the Great and then we don't
have to fight each other anymore. Okay?
And and that's how Cyus the Great was
able to build the first world empire.
Okay? This is um uh Babylon, the fall of
Babylon. And Cyrus the Great um there
are different stories, but one story is
that they basically invited him in in
order to resolve their inner conflicts
with with each other. Okay.
Um,
this is a tomb of Cyrus the Great. It's
still in Iran today. There's a story
that when Action the Great, you know,
who who was Macedonian, when he went to
conquer the Persian Empire, he
discovered that the Cyrus the Great, his
tomb uh was in um bad repair. They
didn't really maintain or upkeep it. So,
he ordered for it to be properly
maintained. Okay, that's probably the
story is is by the way probably false.
But it shows you that at this time in
history about the year 300 400 um
everyone uh uh 300 400 BC everyone was
respectful of sus. Okay. Sus great is
considered the world's greatest king or
emperor.
Okay. So as you can see the persian
empire is huge. Okay. It encompasses
most of uh West Asia. Okay. So, it goes
from Iran all the way to Mesopotamia to
Anatolia to parts of um Greece and all
basically all of Egypt and Libya. Okay.
It's a huge area and they were able to
do this because of their innovations in
religion as well as administration.
Okay. All right. So, let me explain how
do you rule empires usually. Okay. Well,
the traditional way is you control trade
routes and access. Okay. So, people have
to pay you a tax to go through your
trade routes. That that's a tra
traditional way. You can also use fear
and conquest. Then that's what the
Assyrians were known for. They would
come and they would kill everyone if you
disobey them. Uh you took hostage
hostages. That's that's a very common
thing where you conquer people and you
take uh the children of the king as
hostages. Okay. uh in a marriage,
religion, but what the Persians did
really well that allow for the Persian
empire to be so huge as well as to be
really well managed are four four
things. Okay, effective administration.
Again, when you have a religion zism
where people can't lie, that's really
good because these bureaucrats will now
report real facts to the emperor and
that allows him to make better
decisions. Okay, elite cultation
meritocracy. And the idea here is that
if you have a very effective
administration that allows for local
elites to focus your energies on trying
to join this administration as opposed
to rebelling against you uh
communication uh networks, okay? So
things like roads, things like uh uh uh
postal networks. Okay. So, the Persians
create the first uh global postage
system and it was really effective where
uh you want to send mail from Egypt over
to uh Mesopotamia, what would happen is
you would have these royal roads where
uh people would ride on horses and they
could stop at a basically a hostile rest
and then keep on going. Okay. And that
way you can you can um very quickly move
information from one core of the empire
to the other. Okay. And the last is to
divide and rule. Divide and rule is
really important. So what they did was
they basically had different power
centers within a within a region. Okay.
So you had the sat traps which were the
local governors but then you also had
the local you also had the bureaucrats.
Okay. You also had uh the royal
representatives. So these are different
factions within a re within a region.
Okay. So dividing rule is probably the
most effective way to control an empire.
Okay. So now let's move on to Israel.
Okay. We know we now know about the
Persian Empire, how they managed their
system and why they are so effective.
Okay. Now let's talk about Israel. So
remember that we read the Bible. Um and
the Bible um came about because David
needed to justify legitimize his rule.
And after branches collapsed, David
created a devic kingdom um in the Levant
because Egypt, Anatolia, Mesopania were
preoccupied, right? But because Lavant
is so important, this limited kingdom
doesn't really last that long. It lasts
for like 80 200 years. Okay. Um after
Solomon, David's son, dies, Israel is
divided into two parts. The northern
kingdom, which gets conquered by Assyria
as well as Judah. Okay. Jerusalem where
which tries to maintain the the kingdom
but doesn't last very long. At this time
in history
um uh the Israelites are being pulled in
different directions. Okay. The
Anatolians, the Assyrians, the
Babylonians, the Egyptians because they
are strategically very important. And so
what's really hard for these empires is
how do we maintain control over
Jerusalem? Okay. And they try different
techniques. They try um burning down
their city centers. Okay, so the
northern kingdom was destroyed. Uh you
might have heard of the 10 lost tribes
of Israel. Um they tried taking
hostages. Okay, but because this region
is so volatile, nothing really works.
And so the Jew Jerusalem, the Israelites
keep on rebelling. Okay.
Um
so this is king of Judah and [snorts]
what happens is for the longest time the
Babylonians are trying to deal with the
Israelites. Okay? So they take hostages.
Okay? They take hostages like thousands
of them and move them to Babylon where
they become scribes where they become
farmers where they become merchants.
Okay.
Um but again the region is so
strategically important that Jerusalem
uh the Israelites they switch loyalties
all the time. Eventually the Babylonians
are so pissed off that they decided to
burn down their temple. Okay. And so at
this point in history the Israelites are
now gone. Okay. Does that make sense?
The Israelites are gone now. [snorts]
[clears throat]
Um 587
to 6. We don't know when, but Babylon's
destroyed Jerusalem
because they cannot they they they tried
many techniques to try to control
Jerusalem. They can't do it. The
Israelites are too rebellious. Uh but
it's too strategically important. So
they destroy. So so they decide, you
know what, screw this. We'll just
destroy the city. Okay. So when this
happens, okay, that's really important
for you to understand. The Israelites
are gone. Okay, the people are still
around. The identity of the Israelites
are now gone.
>> [sighs]
>> 539 Cyrus the Great conquers Babylon.
Okay. And he says, "I want the
Israelites to return to Jerusalem." It's
called the Edict of Cyrus. All right?
And this is celebrated in the Bible.
What is controversial is why would he do
such a thing? Okay? Because again, the
Israelites are now gone.
um the Israelites who go who went to
Babylonia, they may still keep their
religion a bit, but they no longer have
their land. They no longer they're they
have changed as a people. Okay? So, as
an Israelite, you pray in the temple,
but the temple is now destroyed. So, now
you um pray in a synagogue. Okay? So,
the people have changed a great deal.
So, the question now is why would Cas
the Great go to Babylon and said, "You
know what? I want you Israelites to
return to Jerusalem. I want you to
reconstitute the nation of Israel. Why
would he do that?
Okay. So, this is going to this is a
going to be a debate that will never
ever end. Okay. So, the Bible tells us
that Cyrus the Great did this because
God told him to do that. Really simple.
God says, "I love my people. The
Israelites send them home." Okay? And
Cy, yes, of course, you're the great
God. I'll do so. Okay, guys. That's how
it happened. Okay. All right. So, there
are different explanations. Um, maybe
the idea is that Cyrus wants to show all
the Persian Empire, I'm religiously
tolerant. You can practice your
religion. You can set up your religion.
That's what the Persian Empire is, an
open, tolerant, generous empire. Okay,
that's true. What's also true is that
Cyrus thought himself as a righteous and
merciful king uh who wanted to be
generous to everyone. Okay, so he saw
the Israelites uh want home. He says,
"Well, can go home." Okay. Um he it's
also possible that there's a faction
within the Israelites who supported his
Babylon takeover. Okay, I don't know if
this is true. It's probably not true,
but we consider that consider that as as
a possibility that the Israelites in
Babylon supported his takeover. And so
to thank them, Cyrus said, "Fine, I'll
give you back Jerusalem."
Um, another possibility is that uh when
Cyrus the great conquered Babylon, he
discovered that you know what these
Israelites are really good
administrators and this is true found
history because remember the Israelites
have their Bible and the religion
requires them to study the Bible and as
we discussed the Bible is one of debate,
openness, asking questions and so these
are very literate intellectuals and they
rise up very high in the Babylon
administration. But this is true
throughout history where where Jewish
people will rise very high in all
empires including including the Islamic
empire including u the American empire.
Okay.
Um I think the best reason for what
happened is divide and rule. Okay. So
the idea is that
you need to control the Levant because
Levant gives you access to Egypt which
is historically the wealthiest part of
the world. Okay. Whoever controls Egypt
controls the world. So what you do is
you set up a group of people in the
Levant that are only loyal to you. Okay?
Does that make sense? Okay. You set up
people in the Levant that only exist
because you, the empire, allow them to
exist. If you the empire did not support
them, then the locals, the everyone in
that region would would get rid of them
right away. Okay? And that's why we have
the Jews. So the Jews were invented by
the Persians to control the Leavant. The
Jews is actually a Persian term. Okay.
So before the Jews were of course the
Israelites. Now we have the Jews.
All right. So
um this is Jerusalem. And as you can see
what's really important to understand is
that this is actually only a really
small part of the Lat. But this part is
specifically for the Jews. Um, and it's
part of this Persian province called
Beyond the River. Okay?
>> And they call it the province of Yahoo.
That's that's why we have the term Jews.
Okay? Because they are part of the
province of Yahoo. And and what's really
important to understand is they're
surrounded by enemies. The Samrians are
Israelites who have stayed in the
Levant. Okay? Do you understand?
So most people around them are in fact
Israelites who uh adapted to local
circumstances and that means that they
practice different religions. That also
means that they married foreign women as
well but they still consume as
Israelites. Okay? Right? Does that make
sense guys? [snorts]
So
what but what happens is that these
exiles from Babylon, they come back and
they say, "No, we're the true
Israelites. You guys are the false
Israelites. The reason why we're true is
we have stayed loyal to um our
religion." Okay? So what's going to
happen over the next few decades is
almost a civil war between Israelites
who've stayed and Israelites who left
but come back. All right? All right. And
this is what the Persian Empire wants in
order to maintain stability in the
Levant. Right? Because you have this
small minority um of exiles from Avalon
who've come back and they're in conflict
with everyone else. All right. This is
divine rule. Okay. So um
um could you sorry let let me
>> Okay. Let me Okay. Okay. So could you
help me read the Bible? Okay.
>> Okay.
>> All right. So we're going to read two
books of the Bible. They're called Ezra
and Nhema. Okay. And these two books are
really important and they're not really
discuss that often um by scholars. But
Ezri Namya shows us how
Persia helped the Jews to reconstitute
their nation, the process. And by
studying these two books, it will give
us insight into how current people in
the nation of Israel think. And then we
can analyze how they will behave moving
forward. Okay. All right. So, so can you
read this? This this is the beginning of
the book of Ezra. Okay.
>> In the first year of King Cyrus of
Persia in order that the world of the
Lord by the mouth of Jeremiah might be
accomplished. The Lord stirred up the
spirit of King Cyrus of Persia so that
he sent a herald throughout all his
kingdom and also in a written edict
declared.
>> Okay. So, this is really important for
us to understand. Okay. the Bible. Cyrus
is doing this because God told him to do
this. Okay? Not because of imperial
ambitions or imperial strategy. It's
just God told him to do this. Okay? Keep
on going.
>> Thus says King Cyrus of Persia, "The
Lord, the God of heaven, has given me
all the kingdoms of the earth, and he
has charged me to build him a house at
Jerusalem in Judah.
>> [snorts]
>> any of those among you who are of his
people, may their God be with them, are
now be are now permitted to go up to
Jerusalem in Judah and rebuild the house
of the Lord, the God of Israel. He is
the God who is in Jerusalem, and let all
survivors in whatever place they reside
be assisted by the people of their place
with silver and gold, with goods, and
with animals, besides free will
offsprings for the house of God in
Jerusalem. Okay. So, Cyrus the Great is
considered the Messiah by the Jews.
Um, the Jews are extremely thankful for
Cyrus because not only do they does he
allow them to go back to uh Jerusalem,
but he also finances the rebuilding of
the temple. Okay? But when this happens,
when they go back and try to rebuild a
temple, the locals get pissed off. Okay?
Because like, who are you people? you
you're still our religion like like
what's going on here? Okay. And this
creates a lot of conflict. That's good
for the Persian Empire because they want
this conflict, right? As part of their
divide and rule strategy. Okay.
All right. Uh
>> when the builders laid the foundation of
the temple of the Lord, the priests in
their vestments were stationed to praise
the Lord with trumpets. And the Levites,
the son of
>> the Levites are important. Levites are
actually the priest class of of the
Israelites. Okay, keep on going.
>> The sons of Asaf with symbols according
to the direction of King David of
Israel. And they sang responsibly,
praising and giving thanks to the Lord,
for he is good, for his steadfast love
endures forever towards Israel. And all
the people responded with a great shout
when they praised the Lord, because the
foundation of the house of the Lord was
laid. But many of the priests and
Levites and heads of families, old
people who had seen the first house on
its foundations, wept with a loud voice
when they saw this house, though many
shouted aloud for joy, so that the
people could not distinguish the sound
of the joyful shout from the sound of
the people sweeping. For the people
shouted so loudly that the sound was
heard far away.
>> This is the happiest moment in Jewish
history when they rebuild the temple.
Okay. What they call second temple. And
this is important because the second
temple was destroyed. [clears throat]
And what they want to do now in Israel
is build the third temple. And this is
important because the third temple sits
on the alacic mosque which is the third
holiest site in the Arabic world. So
what this Bible is telling us that
eventually the Israelis will destroy the
Alic mosque so that they can build the
third temple or what they call the
temple of Solomon. Okay.
All right. Can you can you can you
continue? Um
>> uh from when
>> Yeah. When the adversaries
>> When the adversaries of Judah and
Benjamin heard that the returned exiles
were building a temple to the Lord, the
God of Israel, they approached Zeru
Babel and the heads of families and said
to them, "Let us build with you, for we
worship your gods as you do."
>> Okay, so they're saying, "We're
Israelites just as you guys. Okay, we
stayed, but you guys left. So actually
we're better than you are. Okay. Because
we stayed where you left. Okay. Keep on
going.
>> And we have been sacrificing to him ever
since the days of King Srar haden of
Assyri Assyria who brought us here. But
Zir, Zerubbabel, Jerushia, Josh, Joshua,
and the rest of the heads of families.
And Israel said to them, "You shall have
no part with us in building a house to
our God. But we alone will build to the
Lord, the God of Israel, as King Cyrus
of Persia had commanded us."
>> This is really weird, right? You're all
you're all Israelites. Why? Why is it
that No, we are the true Israelites. You
guys are You guys are the false
Israelites, and so you can't help us.
Okay? Why is there this conflict going
on,
right? That's strange.
And so the only way to understand this
is the conflict is part of the imperial
strategy. Okay? Divide and rule. Keep on
going.
>> Then the people of the land discouraged
the people of Judah and made them afraid
to build and they bribed officials to
frustrate the plan throughout the re
reign of King Cyrus of Persia and until
the reign of King Darius of Persia.
>> Okay. So they try to build the temple,
but it doesn't really work out because
there's so much opposition, right? The
the the Jews who come back from Babylon,
it's like, "We're the real Israelites,
so only we can touch the temple. No, no
one else can participate." And the
others are like, "This is not this is
this is wrong.
We should all participate in the
building of the temple. This is this is
one religion." Okay. So it seems as
though these Jews in Babylon, they're
actually imperial agents who are trying
to show discontent within the region.
Okay.
Uh sorry this is a bit long. Okay. But
um c can can you try to read?
>> Okay. This is a copy of the letter that
king and can you help me?
>> Uh art artoxes. Okay.
>> Artex.
>> Artexis is this great warrior in
Persian. Okay. Great warrior. Keep on
going. gave to the priest Ezra, the
scribe, a scholar of the text of the
commandments of the Lord and his status
for Israel.
>> Okay, so Ezra is one of these Israelites
who was who comes from a family that was
exiled to Babylon. Okay, but he's a
priest and he's an intellectual. So he
is considered actually the uh creator of
the Bible that we have today. Okay, keep
on going. Artisex says, "King of kings
to the priest Zarah, the scribe of the
law of the God of heaven, peace. And now
I decree that any of the people of
Israel of their priests or Levites in my
kingdom who freely offers to go to
Jerusalem may go with you. For you are
you are sent by the king and his seven
counselors to make inquiries about Judah
and Jerusalem according to the law of
your God which is in your hand. and also
to convey the silver and gold that the
king and his counselors have freely
offered to the God of Israel who whose
dwelling is in Jerusalem with all the
silver and gold that you shall find in
the whole province of Babylonia and with
the free will offerings of the people
and the priests given willingly to the
house of their God in Jerusalem. With
this money then you shall with all
diligence buy bulls, rams and lambs and
their grain offering and their drink
offerings and you shall offer them on
the altar of the house of your God and
to raise.
>> Okay, stop. Okay, this is really
important. Okay, this is a letter um by
King Ardis authorizing
is Ezra to build the second temple.
Okay, why is this important? because
this is called the Balfford declaration
1917. What's going to happen is that the
British government um Lord Balfford he
writes to Lord Rothst who is a Jewish
finance and he says we uh actually just
just read this. Okay.
>> Okay. I have much pleasure in conveying
to you on behalf of his majesty's
government the following declaration of
empath sympathy with Jewish Zionist
aspirations which has been submitted to
and approved by the cabinet. His
majesty's government view with favor the
establishment in Palestine of a n
national home for the Jewish people and
will use their best endeavors to
facilitate the achievement of this
object. It being clearly understood that
nothing shall be done which may
prejudice the civil and religious rights
of existing non-Jewish communities in
Palestine or the rights and political
status enjoyed by Jews in any other
country. I should be grateful if you
would bring this declaration to the
knowledge of the Zionist Federation.
>> Okay, this is almost like the artist
segregation, right? You see how in the
Bible artists writes a letter to Ash
says, "Hey, I authorize you to go back
to Jerusalem and build the second
temple." Right? So, what's happening is
that they're using the Bible as a script
in order to um facilitate their
geopolitical ambitions. Okay? Okay, this
is why reading the Bible is important
because once you read the Bible, you
understand the Bible, you compare it to
historical development, you're able to
see the connections and you're able to
see connections, you can also see
predict how they will develop over time.
Okay, so this battle of declaration
creates the current nation of Israel,
okay, which was found in 1948.
So like before the nation of Israel was
created by the British as part of their
geopolitical strategy of dividing and
conquering the Middle East and I and
we'll discuss this later on. Okay. But
it's really important for you guys to
keep in mind as we move forward. All
right. Uh c can you um read the
highlighted part? Okay.
>> Okay. Oh my god. I'm too ashamed and
embarrassed to lift my face to you. My
God, for our iniquities have risen
higher than our heads.
>> Okay, so this is a speech by Ezra. Okay,
he returns to Jerusalem and now he has
to reflect on on what God wants. Okay,
so he's he's he's going to discuss why
God exiled in Babylon, why God has
allowed him return, and what God wants
him to do. Okay, keep on going.
>> And our guilt has mounted up to the
heavens. From the days of our ancestors
to this day, we have been deep in guilt.
And for in iniquities, we our kings and
our priests have been handed over to the
kings of the lands, to the sword, to
captivity, to plundering, and to utter
shame as it now the case.
>> Okay. So why did the Israelites get
exiled to Babylon? Because they refused
to obey and worship Yahweh. Yahweh sent
prophets. Yahweh warned them, but they
kept on uh worshiping false gods. They
kept on uh sinning. And so Yahweh is
like, "You know what? I really needed to
teach these guys a lesson." And that's
why they exiled him. They exiled them to
Babylon so they can reflect and learn
and grow as a people. Okay, keep on
going.
No, this case. But now, for a brief
moment, favor has been shown by the Lord
of Lord our God, who has left us a
remnant and given us a stake in his holy
place, in order that he may brighten our
eyes and grant us a little sustenance
sustenance in our slavery. For we are
slaves, yet our God has not forsaken us
in our slavery, but has extended to us
his steadfast love before the kings of
Persia, to give us new life, to set up
the house of our God, to repair its
ruins, and to give us a wall in Judah
>> and Jerusalem
>> and in Jerusalem.
>> Okay, so Ezra is saying, "Okay, yeah, we
screwed up, but God is forgiving, and
now we have a second chance to prove
ourselves to God." How do we prove
ourselves to God? by making sure that we
only worship him. Okay. So this
beginning of um uh Jewish monotheism.
Okay. Which was heavily influenced by
Zorashianism. So in other words um the
religion that the Jews will practice
from now on is not the religion of the
Israelites which is polytheistic. They
they're will now practice a new religion
that's heavily influenced by
Zorashianism. Okay. Which is the Persian
religion. Come on.
>> And now, our God, what shall we say
after this? For we have forsaken your
commandments, which you are commanded by
your servants, the prophet, saying, the
land that you are entering to possess is
a land unclean with the pollutions of
the people of the lands with their
abominations. They have they have filled
it from end to end with their
uncleanness.
>> Okay. So, this is really important idea
to understand. What what Ashra is saying
is this these Israelites who've stayed
are traitors. They are now unclean. Why?
Because now they worship foreign gods.
They're they're polytheistic. And as a
result, we have to clean the land. Okay,
this is a fanatical understanding of
Judaism. Okay, keep on going. Therefore,
do not give your daughters to their
sons, neither take their daughters from
your sons, and never seek their peace or
propriety, so that you may be strong and
eat the good of the land and leave it
for an inheritance to your children
forever.
>> Okay, keep on going. After all that has
come upon us for our evil deeds and for
our great guilt, seeing that you, our
God, have punished us less than our
iniquities deserved, and have given us
such a remnant at this, shall we break
your commandment again, and intermar
with the people who practice these
abominations? Would you not be angry
with us until you destroy us with
without remnant or survivor? Oh Lord,
God of Israel, you are just, but we have
escaped as a remnant, as is now the
case. Here we are before you in our
guilt, though no one can face you
because of this.
>> Okay, so now God has forgiven us. We've
returned to uh Jerusalem. We can't screw
this up again. Okay, and how do we prove
our loyalty to God? By making sure that
we are pure.
Okay, we're not going to marry other uh
religions. We're not going to marry
other people. we're going to be there
within ourselves. So, Heroditus in his
histories when he talks about the Jewish
people, okay, he says the Jewish people
are known for two things. The first
thing they're known for is giving
Sabbath on Saturday. So, they don't
work, they don't work on Saturday
because that's their law. The second
thing that they're known for, really
known for is they don't marry outside
their religion. Jewish women will not
will refuse to marry foreign men. Okay?
And so, now we have the concept of blood
purity. That is new. So remember it's
really important for us to understand
but the Jews and the Israelites are not
the same people. Okay. In fact what
Israel is doing is rejecting the
Israelite heritage and establishing a
new heritage based on blood purity and a
monopistic devotion to Yahweh. And this
is new. Okay. That's why I keep on
saying this. The Jews of Persia are not
the same as the Israelites of David.
All right. So, um, as you can see from
this map,
um, the Jews are in this area and it's a
very small part of the Levant, but it's
a part of the Levant that's completely
loyal to Persia, okay? Because they see
everyone else as unclean, as the enemy.
And if you're an empire, having the Jews
around are really
um good for you, right? All right.
And so
the Jews are an invention of the
Persians, but guess what? The nation of
Israel is also an invention of the
British Empire. And we'll discuss this
later on.
All right. Um so we move on to the
second book called Nhema. So Ezra is the
priest who will create the Bible. Uh
Nehemiah is the uh governor sent by the
Persians to reestablish
uh the Jewish nation. Okay. So okay, can
you read the the highlighted part?
>> At the time I was cupbearer to the king.
>> Okay. Cup bearer to the king is like a
really powerful position, right? Because
you can poison the king. So the king
loves you. The king sees you as um as
someone who is very competent and you
could possibly be one day be um
uh prime minister or the first minister.
Okay, keep on going.
>> In the month of Nissan in the 12th 20th
>> 20th year of King Artist
>> Artisexes
>> Artisexes my bad. when wine has when
wine was served him. I carried the wine
and gave it to the king. Now I had never
been sad in this presence before. So the
king said to me, "Why is your face sad
since you are not s not sick? This can
only be sadness of the heart." Then I
was very much afraid. I said to the
king, "May the king live forever. Why
should my face not be sad when the city,
the place of my ancestors graves, lies
waste and its gate have been destroyed
by fire? Then the king said to me, "What
do you request?" So I prayed to the God
of heaven. Then I said to the king, "If
it pleases the king, and you your
servant has found favor with you, I ask
that you send me to Judah, to the city
of my ancestors grave so that I may
rebuild it." The king said to me, the
queen also was sitting beside him. How
long will you be gone and when will you
return? So it pleased the king to send
me. And I set him a date. Then I said to
the king, "If I pleases the king, let
letters be given to given me to the
governors of the province beyond the
river, that they may grant me passage
until I arrived in Judah." and a letter
to Asaf, the keeper of the king's
forest, directing him to give me timber
to make beams for the gates of the
temple fortress and for the wall of the
city and for the house that I shall
occupy. And the king granted me what I
asked for the gracious hand of my God
was upon me. Okay. So the Bible says
that Nehemiah one day feels tremendous
regret that uh the city of his ancestors
is not has not been rebuilt. Okay? And
he begs the king for permission to go
back. Guys, this is not how empires
work. Okay? This is not how empires
work. You do not ask the king or the
emperor for anything because he will
just cut your head off. Okay? How
empires work is that you have to read
the king's intentions, right? You have
to figure out what does he really want?
And then you have to say please please I
want to do this not because you asked me
to do this but because I want to do this
myself. Okay. And I will work hard to
achieve this ambition. That's how
empires work. All right. The king does
not tell you what he wants. You have to
guess what he wants. If you can guess
what he wants, then you get promoted. If
you can't guess what he wants, then you
get then you get your head cut off. All
right. That's how empires work. This is
important because
um when we move on to the nation of
Israel, most people believe that the
nation of Israel started with the
Zionist movement which came with u the
writing of a book called uh Judand um
fatherland written by this German Jewish
journalist called Theodore Herszel. And
so people say Zionism started 100 years
ago. Guys, when we do the next state of
Israel, we will discover that it's
actually part of the British imperial
policy. Okay? But the British themselves
cannot be seen as the one as the ones
who are promoting the creation of the
state of Israel because it makes them
look bad. Okay? Um because then because
everyone else would be like why are you
doing this? So what they have to do is
create a situation in which the Jews
themselves are trying to are want to
create their own nation. The problem
though is this is really important.
We'll discuss this later is that 100
years ago, guess what? Jews did not want
to go to Jerusalem because they were
happy where they were. Okay? There were
a lot of Jews who were pretty happy in
Babylon, but they were sent back in
order to create this um uh to create
this uh province Judah um and to create
all this conflict with with the locals.
Okay? That's how empires work.
Okay. All right. So, when Nehemiah goes
back, what what he's going to do is he's
going to build the temple and he's going
to build the walls. This is going to
piss everyone off, right? Because like
why would you do that? [clears throat]
We're all living happily together. We're
all big one big family. Um and now
you're building these walls which means
that you're better than us or you or
you're afraid you're you're afraid of us
or you want to conquer us. Okay? So this
creates all these conflicts with the
locals which is again what the Persian
Empire wants to happen. This is how
empires work. [cough]
All right.
Okay. C can you can you read?
>> Now there was a great outcry of the
people and of their wives against their
Jewish kin. For there were those who
said with our sons and our daughters we
are many. We must get grain so that we
may eat and stay alive. There were also
those who said, "We are having to pledge
our fields, our vineyards, and our
houses in order to get grain during the
famine." And there were those who said,
"We are having to borrow money on our
fields and vineyards to pay the king's
tax." Now, our flesh is the same as that
of our kindred. Our children are the
same as their children, and yet we are
forcing our sons and daughters to be
slaves, and some of our daughters have
been ravished. we are powerless and our
fields and vineyards now belong to
others.
>> Okay. So what what's happening is that
Nehemiah has gone back to create this
new province um of Jews. What he's
discovering is that there's massive
corruption inequality among these Jews
and this is a problem because they're
minority in a very hostile region.
Right. Keep on going.
>> I was very angry when I heard their
outcry and these complaints. After
thinking it over, I brought charges
against the nobles, the nobles and the
officials. I said to them, "You are all
taking interest from your own people."
And I called a great embassy to deal
assembly to deal with them. And said to
them, "As far as we were able, we have
brought back our Jewish kindred who had
been sold to other nations, but now you
are selling your own kin who must then
be brought back by us." They were silent
and could not find a word to say. So I
said, "The thing you the thing that you
are doing is not good. Should you not
should you not walk in the fear of our
God to prevent the taunts of the nations
our enemies? Moreover, I moreover I and
my brothers and my servants are lending
them money and grain. Let us stop this
taking of interest. Restore to them this
very day their fields, their vineyards,
their olive work or orchards and their
houses and their interests on money,
grain, wine and oil that you have been
exact exa exacting from [snorts] them.
Then they said, "We will restore
everything and demand nothing more from
them. We will do as you say." And I
called the priests and made them take an
oath to do as they had promised. I also
shook out the folds of my garment and
said, "So many God shakes out everyone
from house and from property who does
not perform this promise. Thus may they
be shaken out and emptied." And all the
assembly said, "Amen." And praised the
Lord. And the people did as they had
promised.
>> Okay, so this is a really important
aspect of the Jews that people don't
really understand how unified they are.
Okay, an example is that if you're a
Jewish person,
you can always get an interest free
interest free loan if you want to buy a
house or start a business.
Okay, that's pretty amazing, right? If
you want to buy a house or want to start
a business, we go to bank, they're like,
um, okay, we're going to charge you 10%
interest and maybe you can't afford
that, right? But if you're a Jewish
person, doesn't matter [snorts] how poor
you are, there will always be Jewish
organizations that can offer you
interest free loans. If you want to
start a business or if you want to buy a
house, you want to do anything because
Jews are not allowed to collect interest
from each other. That's how unified they
are as a people.
Okay. Uh
okay. So, uh, just read the top and they
highlight it and and and that's it.
Okay.
>> Okay. When the seventh month came, the
people of Israel being settled in their
own in their towns, all the people
gathered together into the square before
the Watergate, they told the scribe Ezra
to bring the book of the law of Moses,
which the Lord had had given to Israel.
Accordingly, the priest Ezra brought the
law before the assembly, both men and
women, and all who could hear
hear with understanding. This was on the
first day of the seventh month. He read
from it facing the square before the
water gate from early morning until
midday in the presence in the presence
of the men and women and those who could
understand. and the ears of all of all
the people were were attentive to the
book of the law.
>> Okay. So this is the last step of
creating the Jewish identity. Okay. So
the idea of the Jewish identity is that
um they follow the laws of God. They do
not marry outside their religion. They
not charge each other interest. They
don't exploit each other. Okay. And the
last thing is this. The last thing is
that their historical memory is the
Bible. Okay. Who are we as Jewish
people? H what are our memories? It's
whatever is written in the Bible. Okay.
So Ezra is taking all these historical
documents and he's combined them
together in what today we call the
Bible.
Okay. And this is this makes the Jewish
people extremely resilient because no
matter uh where they are, no matter um
how low the publishing um
um how low the publishing goes, their
memory, their historical identity is
always stored in one Bible. That makes
them the the world's most resilient,
flexible, and open people. Okay. So this
begins the uh uh Bible. Okay. Uh keep on
going.
>> In those days I saw in Judah people
treating wine pre wine presses on the
Sabbath. And
>> Sabbath is a Saturday, the day of rest.
Okay.
>> And bring in heaps of grain and loading
them on donkeys and also wine, grapes,
figs, and all kinds of burdens which
they brought into Jerusalem on the
Sabbath day. And I warned them at the
time against selling food.
>> Ty tyrans
>> Tyrions also who lived in the city
brought in fish and all kinds of
merchandise and sold them on the Sabbath
to the people of Judah and in Jerusalem.
Then Ire remmonstrated
with the nobles of Judah and said to
them, "What is this evil thing that you
are doing profaining the Sabbath day?
Did not your ancestors act in this way?
And did not our God bring all this
disaster on us and on the city? Yet you
bring more worth and on Israel by
profaining the Sabbath. In those days
also I saw Jews who had married women of
Ashdod, Ammon, and Moab. And half of
their children spoke the language of
Ashod, and they could not speak the
language of Judah, but spoke the
language of various people. And I
contended with them, and cursed them,
and beat some of them, and pulled out
their hair. And I made them take an oath
in the name of God, saying, "You shall
not give your daughters to their sons,
or take their daughters from your sons,
or for yourselves." Did not King Solomon
of Israel sin on account of such women.
Among the many nations there were there
was no king like him, and he was beloved
by his God, and God made him king over
all Israel. Nevertheless, foreign women
made even him to sin. Shall we then
listen to you and do all this great evil
and act treacherously against our God by
marrying foreign women?
>> Okay. So, Nehemiah uh enforces two major
laws. The first law is that you shall
not work on the Sabbath because that is
God's rest day. Okay. Second major law
is that if you marry a foreign woman,
you must divorce her. He's bringing up
families. Why? because he believes that
um religious purity requires blood
purity. If you marry a foreign woman,
she's she's going to make you believe in
their foreign god. Remember, it is by
worshiping false idols. Um it's because
of this that Yahweh decided to punish
the Jews. Okay? So, the Jews must only
worship Yahweh.
All right? So, this is their
interpretation of monotheism. So as you
can see um there are certain traditions
uh about the Jews that was created
during the Persian Empire in order to
facilitate Persian's control of the
Lavant. But these traditions because
they are encoded in the Bible they stay
with us even today. But not only that,
but by reading the Bible carefully and
understand how to connect the Bible to
historical development, you can now
figure out how Israel will develop over
the next 10, 20 years. Okay? And these
are my sorry,
see these are my three predictions.
First of all, they're going to rebuild
the temple of Solomon.
Okay? They're going to build the third
temple by destroying the Alex mos.
They're going to do that sooner or
later. Okay? That's the first thing
they're going to do. And and you can you
know why? Because when we when we read
the Bible, you can see how how happy
they were. Okay? Because they felt
completed. They felt as though God is
with us. God has forgiven us. God loves
us. Okay? So building the third temple
is crucial to the identity of Israel
today. Okay? Okay. So, they're going to
do this and it's going to cause a lot of
problems because again the mosque is the
third holiest site in the Islamic world
and it's going to create a lot of
conflict between Israel and the Islamic
world. Okay. Do they care? Not really.
Okay. Number two, you can see how um
when the Jews returned, they were
convinced that
they were forced out of Jerusalem
because they offended God. Okay? So in
other words, if Jews want to maintain
control over Israel, they need to obey
the laws of God, which means that they
have become a theocracy. Okay? Now, now
I'm not sure if you've been to Israel.
I've been to Israel. And if you go to
place like Tel Aviv, it's a very open,
liberal, cosmopolitan, forwardlooking
place. Okay? I think that um Tel Aviv
has um one of the world's highest
concentrations of gays in the world.
Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> Guess what? That's that's gone. Okay. As
Israel develops over time, it's become
more and more of a theocracy where the
Bible is the law. Okay? And the third
thing is that we we can expect that as
the past past Judea expands, more and
more Jews will return to Israel. Look,
the reality is this. If you look at the
Middle East, [clears throat] Israel is
the greatest power in the Middle East.
There's no force in the Middle East that
can prevent Israel from expanding and
expanding including the pacts Judea
which is their ambition. Okay. So um
this is just an introduction but the
thing I want you guys to remember is
that first of all the Jewish identity it
is uh fluid. It's flexible. It's open.
It was created by empire for the purpose
of maintaining empire. Okay. And we're
going to see this throughout history as
well. All right. So, um, is was this
clear to you guys? Are there any
questions about today? Okay. Yeah.
So, how does the the Persian state
control like Persian control of
uh of Jerusalem
transfer to modern day society? Like,
how does it still work? because I think
we're seeing like a a trend that
is Israel's going kind of more back to
to like depending on the Bible and
everything. So, how does it like
transfer to modern day society and all
the conflicts that's happening?
>> Okay, so Persia wanted to divide and
conquer the Leavant. Okay. They're
afraid that if one if the vant becomes
too stable, the lavant might settle with
Egypt or another power and they lose
control of the lavant um which directly
impacts your capacity to trade and
control um the world. Okay. So the way
you control the lavant is you create
this entity
um that has conflict with everyone else.
And now what happens is that both this
entity um
um Jerusalem and the its enemies rely on
you Persia to manage a conflict. Okay?
And this what's happening today in
Israel because who's the empire?
America's the empire, right? Israel has
all these conflicts with nations in the
Middle East, right? They have conflicts
with Turkey. They have conflicts with
Egypt. They have conflicts with uh the
Gulf nations. They have conflicts with
basically everyone. Okay. So, who does
everyone require need to manage this
conflict? America, right? Saudi Arabia,
Israel, Turkey, Egypt, they all require
the United States to come in and say,
"Hey guys, let's just get along. We're
just one big family." Okay? This is all
intentional in order for America to
maintain dominance over the Middle East.
Who's very unhappy about this? Which
nation is very unhappy about this?
Israel. Okay.
Right. Israel is going to piss about
this. So we can expect that over time
what's going to happen is a major major
conflict between America and Israel.
There's going to be a divorce basically.
And my argument to you is that um Israel
will win this conflict and as a result
Israel will become the dominant power in
the Middle East because the Jews know
their own history. The Jews read the
Bible every day. They know what the
Persians did. They know what the British
did. They know what the Americans are
doing today. They don't like they don't
they don't want this. They don't they
don't want to become a servant a slave
to empire.
>> They are ser servant and slave to their
god but they don't become a servant and
slave to the empire. So they need to get
rid of the empire and establish a
sovereignty.
>> Okay? And that's why there's so much
conflict in the Middle East today
because Israel needs to figure out how
to get rid of the American Empire so
that they can be independent and um
fully achieve their sovereignty. Okay.
That does that make sense?
>> Yeah. I think one question I have is
about like I think currently the Jews
stop attacking Palestines. Okay guys,
okay, this is really important. Okay,
don't say the Jews. Okay, there are
different groups. There's the
Israelites. The Israelites are the time
of King David. They're gone. Okay, let's
forget the Israelites. There are the
Jews and the Jews are people who
practice Judaism. Okay, then there are
the Israelis. Israelis are citizens of
the nation of Israel. It's the Israelis
that are doing this, not the Jews.
There's a difference, okay? The because
the Jews are spread out throughout the
world, okay? What we call the Jewish
diaspora. And there are a lot of Jews in
the world who oppose the nation of
Israel because well, what nation nation
of Israel is is doing they believe goes
against the will of God. Okay. So,
Israelis not Jews. Okay.
>> Okay. So the Israelis is
I think like the news just disappears
about how Israelis attacks Palestine.
It's just because
previously is it was like all on those
host searches but recently we can just
it's just just gone the newses.
>> Okay. Um look the reality is that if you
read the Bible it's clear what's going
to happen. Uh, Israel is going to clear
the West Bank and Gaza of Palestinians
to re to establish their theocratic
state. Okay? They can't have
Palestinians and Arabs around. It has to
be completely Jewish.
Um, and these Palestinians can be moved
elsewhere to Jordan, to Egypt. They
don't really care. Okay. But but this
process process will take time.
Okay. Okay. All right. Any more
questions, guys?
Okay, great. So, um was this clear? The
the ideas in this class were are clear.
Okay, so next class what we will do is
we will do the Greek Empire. Okay, and
then after that we'll do the Roman
Empire and after that we will do
Christianity. Okay, so we're going
through history fairly quickly. But um I
want I need you to keep these ideas in
mind because they will build on top of
each other. Okay. All right. Okay. Thank
you.